[Music]
[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
so uh today's podcast episode number 208
is inspired by my level of curiosity
by uh what's going on in Brazil I'm a
big uh if you follow my content I'm a
big fan of Ironton Senna I fell in love
with this guy watches podcast a few
hundred times uh the more I watch his
documentary the more I fall in love with
uh how the people loved him I I love
this guy so much to the point where I
named my daughter after my daughter's
name is Senna s-e-n-a named after art
and Senna so I started tweeting about
Brazil what's going on and I wanted to
invite some people to come down here and
talk and I was watching all these videos
is it true is it not is it fake is it
real is it a conspirin what is really
going on in Brazil you know it's a
certain words you can't talk about and
then all of a sudden I read an article
talking about the director of CIA went
and visited Brazil last year to talk
about bolsonaro you cannot challenge the
elections and I said why is the USA
metaling in the Brazilian election by
sending the director of CIA and this is
documented that's a little bit weird and
then seeing the fact that China is
looking at Brazil as a country tree to
take over and that's a little too close
to America This concerns me as a
businessman because this concerns me as
a family man I wanted to learn more I
posted I said who would you suggest me
having on the podcast we got a bunch of
lists we looked at him we invited people
from both sides unfortunately we only uh
some people from uh uh the left didn't
want to come down so today we have two
guests here with us and I want him uh I
want to properly introduce these folks
one I got a friend of mine here who also
runs one of our offices in the pH Boost
from Honduras one of my favorite guys
one of the smartest guys we got in the
company very very successful businessman
from New York to Florida Marvin it's
great to have you on this the first one
we'll do it uh secondly we have uh two
guests here one is Rodrigo
Constantine who is the president of the
Brazilian liberal Institute and a
founding member of The Institute
Millennium uh he's uh written many books
one of the books is called es escarda
caviar which means caviar left great
Title by the way uh he graduated in 98
from a political uh from uh pontifical
Catholic University of Rio De Janeiro
and in 2000 he obtained a masters of
Business Administration in finance from
ipmec in Rio de Janeiro as well if I'm
pronouncing it correctly it is thank you
for being on and we also have Paolo uh
figuero figuerido it's hard
by the way it's a uh that last name is
known in Brazil because he is the former
he is the grandson of the former
president joa am I saying joao same last
name figuerto and he is a businessman
Economist and journalist he holds a
specialization in business international
relations and political economy from the
London School of Economics certification
American government from Harvard
University and in microeconomics from
MIT so thank you for being a guest on
the podcast my pleasure so uh look as an
American we have so much already going
on in America to keep track of what's
going on from here I'm from Iran so I
track what's going on with Iran I'm
Armenian so I'm watching what's going on
Armenian I'm Assyrian I'm a businessman
so I'm keeping track with the economy I
don't have time to track what else is
going on in many of these other
countries but because we run the podcast
because the world is becoming smaller
today we're all connected uh I want to
learn a little bit more about what's
going on with Brazil so
um Lula wins uh the election according
to the data that the world gets I think
it's like 50.9 to 49.1 percent some
numbers like that that you see all over
the place some are saying this is not
accurate the Supreme Court was involved
there's a lot of different things why
don't you help us give us a little bit
of understanding of what's going on in
Brazil right now
well you got to go back a little bit in
history to understand that the Lula was
the president uh and his party they were
in power for 13 years in Brazil okay
from 2003 to 2015.
and then uh
uh his successor uh lady uh called Juma
hussef she was impeached
for defrauding Public Accounts okay
and in the meantime the largest
corruption Scandal and I think the
history of the world was being
investigated and most of Lula's Minister
and dilma's Minister were being arrested
and investigated you're talking about
operation Car Wash operation Car Wash
that's correct and
um so the Duma wasn't impeached because
of operation Car Wash she was impeached
by defrauding Public Accounts
but it was all connected because you had
we had large large demonstrations on the
streets in Brazil large I mean probably
among the largest in the world's history
we were together in many of them uh and
was a succession of demonstration so
then she was impeached we got a her vice
president took over
a guy a little more to the center uh
Michelle or Michelle Tamer
[Music]
um
and and um in 2018 we had elections so
everyone thought that Brazil would get a
present from the center left because
Brazil for many years had a division
between the center left uh psdb it was a
party central left party Social Democrat
Party in Brazil and PT the workers party
okay
so bolsonaro got elected and that was a
big surprise it got stabbed in the
middle of the election he was stabbed by
a
he was attacked by a leftist activist
a case that was never properly
investigated because well the the
federal police the clips of it are out
there by the way while he's being
carried by somebody and then he gets
stabbed in the chest and he nearly died
yeah really died he went through uh
several surgeries
um the case was never properly
investigated but they concluded that he
was a lone wolf okay
uh although well I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna get into this Rabbit Hole okay uh
the point is he got elected and
immediately after he got elected The
Establishment was in shock
he was in shock and I'm talking about a
guy that has similarities to Donald
Trump in the United States very it was
he was a very uh
small Congressman in Brazil not part of
any big parties was always like
sidelined uh and and and that was weird
the Press hated him because most of his
policies were very conservative and very
not only conservatives but National
populace okay if you want to call it
that way
uh and and establishment started to
fight him so now we have a second actor
which is very important in Brazil which
is the Supreme Court
so the Supreme Court in Brazil is very
powerful to the point that Americans
could never understand and it's even
hard for us in Brazil to understand how
they became so powerful because it's not
within the Constitution the amount of
power they have right now
so they immediately tried to undermine a
lot of things he was doing but by the
way just just to and I want you to
continue because this is very good
narrative so everybody understand in U.S
right now it's five to four on the on
the right is it true that in Brazil it's
a nine to nine uh to two
so eight of the current Supreme Court
Justices we have 11 in total eight of
them were appointed by the well seven by
the Workers Party correct me if I'm
wrong seven by the workers party uh and
Lula and Zuma yep and another one which
is Alicia Del Maraj was appointed by
Michelle Tamer which was the vice
president of Duma
okay and and before he continues just
one thing that is important they are not
judges you don't need to be a judge to
become a Justice in the Supreme Court in
Brazil what do you mean by that they are
not judged you have to be an attorney
some of them legal background but yeah
background but not a judge yeah yeah all
right they say you have to be you have
to have notable knowledge of the law
okay who elects them is it similar to us
were you the same president okay got it
but but there's a difference between so
by the way shout out to you know a
credit to Lula for flipping seven
because Trump flipped three so many
times when the president flips in and I
want you to give us how it was done but
many times a lot of people sit there and
say well Trump won an election one term
he's a one-term president but he's the
only guy that's ever flipped three seeds
so whether the left or the right that
does that you can control for 20 years
so they flipped seven whether they
flipped seven on that proper way I don't
know that but it's it's a it was it was
improperly they they the president can
the in Brazil
differently from the U.S the Justice
retired so they changed the law a little
bit to make them retire a little bit
earlier but okay that's that was done at
least interesting following the law but
that was not the the whole problem the
problems that the Senate was under
corruption
was the name of the uh like a monthly
payment corrupt payment and they
approved the names one of them Apollo
mentioned that you need to show some
knowledge legal knowledge and all that
one of them tried to be a judge and
failed twice yes and he was failed at
that and he was an attorney from the the
pity the labor party the worker party so
he was very connected to Lula and jigsaw
in all the names and he was approved
because the Senate was under corruption
that's important to me by the way guys
for the people that don't know because
that that statement about uh bolsonaro
and Trump having so many similarities
Can you hire highlight some of them so
that people can understand why he ended
up with that label yeah
okay he's a national
very high popularity and programs uh
yeah so populism not capitalism no no he
his Pro capitalism uh globalization
uh his program his uh against abortion
so yeah very right-wing uh professional
family values and all that freedom got
it got it yeah so go back to your
Supreme Court while you were going
through it so Supreme Court happens I
want to later on come back to Alexandre
de uh I'm really curious about him and
another one as well but please continue
well so brought a very good point so
under PT's the workers party uh
government
they controlled Congress by two
different ways so in the beginning they
did a thing called men Salon men Salon
means a monthly payment okay so they
found out and that was I'm talking about
public records okay people were
convicted it's not a crazy uh yeah uh
conspiracy theory okay that's I'm
talking about public records people
being try even the had minister of Lula
was Tried by the Supreme Court in
2007 I guess or something like that and
he was convicted the main the chief of
uh the chief of civil cabinet uh and and
Lunas was convicted and several other
ministers so it's it's a thing it
happened they were bribing
uh Congressman taking money laundering
money from um uh from public companies
so they was used to uh create this phony
contracts with public companies mostly
uh advertising contracts uh a guy named
Marcus Valerio used to withdraw the
money like cash and and give uh cash to
congressmen that voted with the
government so that's and it was a good
point that he brought up that was one of
the ways they got the the they were able
to appoint as many justices as they
wanted because they had the Congress
they controlled both houses with bribe
okay uh then this was discovered and
and that was that was a problem in
Brazil we don't know how but Lula got
re-elected even after all this I don't
know if people I don't know if our
elections were corrupted back then as
well no one knows because it was the
same system okay but he got reluctant
and when he got reluctant he tried a
different method this this method it was
the one that was investigating our
operation Car Wash which was also
getting money from from public companies
that's why it's so important to
privatize everything uh they got money
from public companies and instead of
giving cash to congressmen they use the
money to finance campaigns okay under
the table
everything under the table
so this way they control both house but
anyways back to the impeachment in
pigment then Supreme Court so Supreme in
just one information to illustrate what
he's saying there's one politician very
close to to Lula and all that they found
10 million dollars in cash at his home
10 million dollars in cash and so that's
what was going on in Brazil that time
yeah it was it was very corrupt to the
point that the following uh strong man
in in lulus and dilma's government
a guy called Antonio palaci he was a
former Ministry of economy and then
Ministry of civil cabinet he on his uh
collaboration with the Justice his deal
plea deal with the
he said he stated that there was no deed
on Lula's Administration or Dumas
Administration that was not uh tainted
by corruption so everything that the
government did
everything you wanted a law approved
okay give me your percentage uh you want
uh to get this contract give me a
percentage this is how so Brazil was
completely completely uh under the mud
of corruption okay this this was what's
going on if we if we want to stay there
for a second and let's just highlight a
little bit more deeper operation Car
Wash okay I'll tell you what I found and
then you tell me if this is correct or
if you want to add anything to it okay
so operation Car Wash uh uh biggest
corruption in history of Brazil ever uh
and leave the world yeah I mean I've
heard world I've heard obviously Brazil
but it's it's political biggest
corruption you read about uh then the
people know what's happening the some of
the people that voted for Lula they say
everybody steals from us but we like
this guy you know at least this guy
gives us some of the money that he's
also stealing he gives it to us as well
that's what I've heard some people say
now that may be right or wrong uh when
this took place there was this uh
perfect place where they were building
this ambitious energy project itabori uh
in Brazil estimated to create 200 000
jobs it was 45 kilometers square
kilometers and during this time when
they're going through this uh project it
caused Lula to uh go to jail for 12
years which she only did 580 days give
or take at this federal police
headquarters in city of curitibia if I'm
not mistaken his successor Dilma was
impeached then her success successor
Michelle was charged for corruption the
former CEO of odebrecht Marcelo de
brecht went to jail for 19 years the
case showed that the company paid 788
million dollars in bribes in connection
with more than a hundred projects in 12
different countries from 2001 to 2006
Elite Batista which at one point was the
richest man
with a net worth of 35 billion dollars
in 2012 the next year his net worth goes
from 35 billion to 200 million dollars
the following year according to
Bloomberg in 2014 his net worth is minus
one billion dollars he went to jail for
30 years in 2016 11 projects were
stalled in Brazil alone due to this
corruption 17 projects were stalled in
seven other countries Cuba Guatemala
Honduras Dominican Republic Colombia
Peru Venezuela Argentina one irrigation
project in Peru where three former
presidents were accused of taking money
from obrecht and eventually this
operation Car Wash Scandal cost
Brazilians 500 000 jobs now here's the
thing if something like this happens and
Lulu's name is tied to it when he left
you see the numbers his popularity was
eighty percent ninety percent you read
stats like that how does a person like
this come back and is able to run and
win because you know in America they'll
say well look at Biden's corruption look
what they've done Biden's never done
time in jail we don't have presidents
that have done jail time in us and come
back and they get elected some people
want to have many of our presidents go
to jail some people say that guy belongs
in jail this guy belongs in jail but
this guy actually went to jail and he
got caught stealing money and bribery
and he wins how does that happen in a
country like Brazil that's a very good
question Patrick and I think we need to
go to the media to answer that like a
lot of similarities what uh what's going
on in Brazil that what happened
two years ago in United States so the
narrative they have is that bolsonaro
just like Trump is a huge threat to
democracy he's a fascist he's gonna uh
took power and never leave and all that
so with this narrative the media goes
against bolsonaro in every detail like
with very fake news narratives and uh
and by the same way but at the same time
uh the Supreme Court releases Lula finds
that the judge responsible for his first
uh condemnation he was convicted he was
considered guilty guilt but in the first
decision
the judge behind the the car wash
operation he's fine like uh uh he he
he's a suspicious he's he has political
interests so uh they release Lula and
after many years
they kind of find a problem with the ZIP
code oh Lula was not supposed to be
judged by the car wash operation the
legal system in kurichiba he was
supposed to be judged in Brasilia and
they find it uh four or five years later
and then they considered Lula able to
run again which was not possible by law
in Brazil so to understand and to answer
uh what what's going on in Brazil and to
answer your question it's very important
to understand the whole system and I
mean the Supreme Court the the Congress
and the media the 90 of the media they
were trying to help Lula go back to
Power because they want bolsonaro out of
it they want to get rid of bolsonaro
that's the first goal so they try many
different names in the center left Paulo
mentioned that there's kind of uh a
fight among the left they try many names
in the center left no one worked because
they they don't have the popularity and
Lula still has some especially in the
the poor parts of Brazil so they try
many names and then they came with Lula
with this kind of rigged decisions uh to
to get rid of bosunar that's what
happened and and you you ask if we hold
mostly the same opinions uh and and we
do I think that's the area we differ a
little bit uh because I agree with 99 of
what he's had so what happens that
establishment noticed after bolsonaro
got elected they were so surprised and
they were like what's going on what what
what the hell is going on here the
Russia collusion was not a thing in
Brazil but WhatsApp uh and robots and
the same the same excuses to why the sky
which they portrayed as the Devil
Himself how this guy
so they were like okay who can beat this
guy
no one
so the like he mentioned the center guys
they were like dull politically no big
names
and they were okay uh I think we need to
re-establish uh Lula's reputation
so he was a and I agree with him he was
uh
uh a union between
the media the mainstream media big role
in that big role they shifted 180
degrees so you've got the same news
anchors like Jonah Maine like our uh CBS
Evening News okay global global yeah
Global you got William Bonner the same
guy that was like Lula was convicted of
corruption to two years later he was
like oh Luna you've been acquitted in
all courts it's like no you have not so
what happened is that yes so the media
the Supreme Court with the Justice
appointed by Lula and the elites I'm
talking about financial markets as well
the Academia everyone the whole
establishment they all got together and
say we gotta we gotta support do that
and that's how they rebranded and
re-established this reputation but that
being said that was only possible in my
humble opinion because operation car
wash
became a power grab and in the middle in
the middle of it okay but they lost
their ways but I have a question for
both of you guys you know I mean because
this is this is there's a very important
statistic that he's providing right now
he gets out of office after being
elected not once but twice but 83
approval so if you have to make an
assessment and share with us what what
would you say that he actually did right
during the time that he was a president
to come out with that kind of right now
right now bosonero bolsonaro is is a 50
which represents you know I mean the the
country's divided but he obviously did a
few things right for the whole country
what were you the country is divided and
if you look at the poor parts of the
Brazil That's where Lula still has uh
some relevance But to answer you it's
important to go back to 2003 correct and
remember what happened to the world it
was uh the China play like Brazil is a
Commodities uh country and we export a
lot of uh uh food and all that uh so in
China is a main partner so uh what
happened is that Brazil was able to
inflate its economy it was not
sustainable and that's very important to
understand because what happened after
Lula gave money to everybody and the
credit was a very let me let me give you
a number okay to to what he's saying uh
when Lula took office uh Brazil the
federal government budget was 600
roughly 600 billion Brazilian cash okay
when Duma was impeached the federal
budget was 1.4 trillion
so
they the the one of the reasons is
because of what Rodrigo is saying
because of the wealth that the exporting
Commodities to China and and the
development of the country the federal
government had more than twice as as
much money as they used to during Lula's
and Dumas uh term and even though Juma
was a huge failure but people uh don't
necessarily uh associate it with Lula so
that that's part of the answer but to
tell you the truth I don't believe Lula
has this kind of popularity right now we
don't see that on the streets we see
bolsonaro's fans but we don't see lulas
the the issue is that a lot especially
the the upper classes they hate
bolsonaro so the the vote to vote in
Lula is not necessarily to want him back
is that you want bolsonaro out of it so
it that's part of this and I understand
what you're saying but but remove China
for a moment right and and I understand
everything that you're saying on terms
so that injection or capital everything
comes out the fact of the matter I want
to go back to that point it's important
though right because what we're trying
to do is we want to make sure that we we
do have an honest approach to the whole
situation right now you know I mean by
the way I was born in Honduras so I know
corruption and I'm willing to accept
that a lot easier than most people I
think in this country and even Latin
America right now are behaving naively
when it comes to this point however
however
it can't just be China though he was
able to do a number of things run so I'm
asking you can you name a few things
that you will say that he absolutely did
right I can yeah yeah I think I think
Bosa Familia which is a a a program of
social well welfare uh distribution it's
always like a food stamp program in
Brazil he implemented that he was most
people were against it I was as well in
the beginning it was more on the liberal
side of the economy you were younger
younger exactly that was uh and and uh
it was that was that was a good program
it was very important uh program to
Brazil for people uh there are in
Desperate condition uh and again because
he had more money he was able to do a
lot of uh public projects and that's a
lot of it but the the main reason if you
ask me the main reason I would have to
tell you
so Reuters okay they publish a report
every year
about the trusts in the media okay how
much people trust in the media if you if
you get the numbers in the U.S right now
they're around 20 20 of the people trust
the mainstream media most of the time
that's correct that's the the general
number in the US if you take Republicans
this number is under 10 right now
in Brazil in 2009 okay under Lulu's
government that number was 70 percent
right now it's 48 this year so media
media media's trust is Plumbing in
Brazil right now but it's still 48 48 of
Brazilian people trust the media which
is
extremely liberal or leftist to be more
precise
I know you interviewed Jordan Peterson I
like to be precise with my speech
so so and Global because of the wrong
reasons they want money to tell you the
truth that's what's behind it they want
money bolsonaro was not given as much
money as Lula so uh they they are
against bolsonaro Global lies every day
to the public and there is a huge
inference and Marvin you mentioned
Honduras and it's very important to
understand that in Latin America and
look at our neighbors in Brazil they are
all left-wing right now they are very
very radical left-wing uh governments
right now the photo de Sao Paulo is very
important to understand Lula started it
in nine in the 90s uh with uh Fidel
Castro and uh there there are many poor
people in Brazil uh they don't know a
lot about communism correct so it's it's
easy to to attract those kind of people
in Brazil with those lies with populism
and that's what happened so Lula is
still a little bit popular but we don't
see that on the streets that's very
important to to to to to bring here
because uh we see the numbers is Joe
Biden popular do you think Joe Biden is
popular the most popular president of
all time
but let me do this it's amazing let me
let me go do this what I wanna what I
want to find out is I want to find out a
little bit more about how bolsonaro
created all this momentum who the best
president uh like the Lincoln or the
Reagan or the JFK of Brazil is I want to
go kind of learn a little bit about
history I go to Brazilian restaurant
every Sunday and I always ask these guys
tell me about Brazil what's going on
with this and they're all Brazilian it's
the uh what do you call the model where
they keep bringing barbecue I love it
yeah so I want to go a little bit more
in the history but let's first give a
quick shout out to our sponsors here
fund and grow uh these guys came to my
attention you know we started looking at
these guys at what they're doing as a
small business owner it's very important
to have your finances in the right place
and protect yourself because you know
your money is what allows you to live
and survive to be able to build your
business so they grab my attention it's
a small business built by helping other
small businesses Thrive they offer a
12-month business credit card stacking
membership that gives entrepreneurs and
small businesses an alternative to
traditional funding over the last 15
years funding grow has cultivated a way
to separate your business finances from
your credit and prevent the risk of your
personal assets as collateral throughout
the membership fund and grow maintains
the credit cards at zero percent
interest so that you can effortlessly
manage your day-to-day businesses
without giving up any kind of equity so
outside of that if you don't have a
business yet but you have an idea
they're also going to help you set up a
complimentary LLC and sole proprietary
ship saving you money with lawyers
and attorneys you have to pay for so the
first thing we look at is anytime we do
a company that wants to work with us we
look at the reviews to see what the
market says about them you can simply
Google them they got 2 400 uh 4.9 stars
out of five which is very very
impressive great reviews from their
clients so I want you to check out their
in-depth Business Credit Card Master
Class by their core page which will put
the link below uh you can go to fund and
growth spell.fund and grow.com forward
slash pbd to watch the educational
webinar and when you sign up today
you'll get a 500 off their 12-month
funding program which by the way is a
tax write-off for your business again
that's
www.fundandgrow.com forward slash pbd go
check out their webinar and once you do
you'll get 500 off your membership
they've helped over 30
000 businesses and they can help you as
well let's put the link below for folks
to go visit them so Lula 83 popularity I
go back and I look at some of the stuff
with this guy to see what he did in the
80s when he's come coming up he's a
lathe
operator in a factory okay so what he
was doing uh but he was a community
organizer right became the president of
meta laureges Union uh this was at the
time where they were holding many
strikes you know for the workers and he
was kind of like a uh I don't want to
say Jimmy Hoffa but he was a union uh
name going out there hey it's not fair
this is not enough money we lost strike
let's do this so he kept encouraging
people to strike but then in 1990 when
uh Fernando color de Melo won this I
think this was his first time losing or
second time he's lost a few times for
presidency he started Sao Paulo Forum in
Brazil which was officially created by
Fidel Castro and Luis inacio uh with
with him so in a time like this and the
whole outcome was hey organization is
going to bring people together from
political parties and left this
organization from all over Latin America
and the Caribbean where with a very
clear here in public plan of Power with
what they want to do anyways so when
they created this at the time in Brazil
how was how did Brazil view Fidel Castro
at this time did the people see him as a
hero did they see him as a man this guy
cares about the poor people and if Lula
is going to be like that or was there
not momentum created yet for Lula
good point listen in Brazil is very
in terms of the political view and all
that Fidel Castro is a hero for a lot of
people especially in the universities
so and the upper classes they love like
a this narrative oh a guy that went
against a dictator uh dictatorship uh
and took power to help people and they
loved that so the education in Cuba uh
the the the social uh Health in Cuba
free healthcare yeah freedom of care
they love this narrative but uh well
nowadays I think they understand uh at
least the majority they understand it
sucks so uh and and just for you to
understand during the many years there's
one there was only one guy that we both
know and and he passed away a few years
ago and he was very important to the
right movement
there was only one guy in the media
talking about this the photo of the Sao
Paulo only him and in the mainstream
media they were pretty in it as a
conspiracy theory like no that that
doesn't exist the left is not United to
bring back to Latin America what they
lost in the in Europe so they they
thought it was a lie but yeah many
people still think Fidel Castro is a
kind of hero and uh but with the social
media uh now many many people can
understand better what's going on in
Cuba and all that so there was no it's
important for you guys to understand
there was no right wing movement in
Brazil uh back then and we are talking
about less than a decade ago there was
no right-wing movement there were only
one guy there one another guy there and
that's it is it is it fair to say like
when I read about both of these guys of
politicians in the history of uh Brazil
the two most strongest personalities who
are loud who are you know charismatic
it's these two bolsonaro and Lula is
that a fair assessment where they're
very good at selling their vision and
casting their vision and speaking to
their base and historically there's not
been even JK who's known as your goat
you know he's one of the greatest
presidents you guys have had you know
they they view him as somebody a lot of
people tell me this based on what I'm
reading maybe you may correct me on that
you don't typically hear somebody that
is you know they're more more poised the
way they speak you know hey here's what
we do this is what Brazil is all about
so was that one of the reasons why both
of these guys got the kind of love that
they got I guess so yeah and they were
both both populous but I have a
different different flavors
but to the sense that they appeal to the
common man more than to the to the
establishment but I have to say I've
never seen
anyone like bolsonaro and in the sense
of how much people likes him it's even
more than people likes Donald Trump
which is Progressive which is impressive
and I've been in both in rallies of both
of them and and I met both of them as
well
and I have to say I I think people
people look at bolsonaro because Donald
Trump is Donald Trump he's the
billionaire in a skyscraper in New York
he's not a common man he talks and
appeals to the common man but he's not a
common guy so Bosa now is the guy that
eats in the steakhouse and drops fat off
a flower on his lap it's like it's a
very and he sincere yeah there's things
here people people see you guys you you
get what you pay for like you can trust
him he's been genuine and it's very
different from uh mainstream uh
politicians it's not like Donald Trump
Palace that has gold and everything it's
more like if you he's so first time I
talked to him he was wearing a jersey
watching a game like with his belly uh
this is like what it's this guy's this
guy's the president and and he's that's
the way he is and it's really people say
sorry I meant Donald Trump yeah and he
is
exactly the same guy that you see on TV
yes but that guy is not a regular Common
Man American uh blue collar worker
bolsonahari is a regular Brazilian guy
they're like sucker ordinary guy
ordinary but but even the way you get to
promote yourself though when you're
running for an election especially a
presidential election there's some very
specific restrictions in Brazil that we
don't have here right so can you go into
that a little bit also because I think
that most people don't know that in here
you can just go race on Capital gets on
money and and you up and running
promoting yourself uh bolsonaro did not
have devotee to promote himself when he
was running for the first time because
he's got to be organized in a very
specific weight how does it work though
and what he have to do to overcome that
very specific limitation he couldn't go
to regular media he couldn't go he
didn't spend money he won a presidential
election with like four million one
million
less than one million dollars even even
if he wanted
even if he wanted to by the way even if
he wanted to he couldn't because the
median The Zone restrictions media wise
right you need the parties correct you
have to be organized yes correct you
need the parties uh they use public
money in one party in Brazil yeah you
can can run as an independent yeah
that's the line how many how many
parties are there for many one many 31
yeah okay got it but you need a party
and the party use uh public money yeah
yeah so who's so can I go campaign and
raise a billion and a half or two
billion like Hillary Clinton Obama no
you can't no there's no more uh company
uh money anymore they they passed the
law many years ago after after car wash
actually who passed the law
okay what do you guys think about the
fact that money can't be involved in
politics well I think it's worse to have
a public money like a taxpayers money so
public money can be private money can't
so you want to use my money to go
campaign for your election for the guys
you don't want to vote isn't this the
replacement she did that right she used
a bunch of the money and she got caught
the money yeah exactly I got you so okay
so going back for the question you ask
because that's very important if you can
address it no it's very important to
understand what what happened this
election because
you were talking
the first time he was elected correct
the first time that was the the knife
issue and and that helped him a lot but
this time the we have in Brazil uh
Electro Justice correct like it's a
branch of uh the Supreme Court uh three
justices uh from the Supreme Court uh
takes uh uh they control the this
electoral Justice and it's very
important what he's saying that Brazil
system is very different from the US U.S
has a state election system okay in
Brazil it's so centralized yeah into a
all-powerful court yes okay this court
has all the power and and we can't get
into the details on how they even became
more powerful during this election they
gave themselves more Powers which is a
different subject but the system it's
first all electronic no Paper Trails
okay everything's done through a machine
uh and it's all centralized in a
superior electoral Court the court is
composed by judges and justices so the
main guys are three guys from the
Supreme Court and then we're gonna come
to Alexandra de mores but this is the
most important name here today I think
so yeah so uh he was the one him and
Sergio Mora I want to know about Sergio
moros yeah but let's start off with
Alexander first no because this guy is
like seriously like he's the where did
he go he's a bad guy from my question
before we move on to that well my
question is he absolutely couldn't
compete at the same level so where did
he go he have to go dude
that first one first one he gets elected
he doesn't have the structure he he
doesn't have the organization so he
doesn't have access to the money he goes
where social media doesn't it yeah
social media so that's another
similarity he's with Donald Trump he
actually gets elected but he doesn't
have the money he did it with a million
dollars he was at his place we're not
talking he was a small country no no his
place he took a microphone uh a church
cell phone turn on the camera in a
Chip's cell phone it was like uh hi my
name is bolsonaro and that's it and like
million millions of views and it was
very organic very uh natural what
happened you know he's a juggernaut on
social media he's uh I I don't I've
never seen anyone like him not even
Donald Trump it's unbelievable the the
level of Engagement that people yeah
which one does he use so he's got a
YouTube
is he is he all across like Facebook
because Trump was mainly Twitter and
Facebook no he's all across he's it he
has a weekly live on Thursdays he used
to uh have a weekly live on Thursdays
that would always get a lot of you where
is he right now home he's in Brazil
right now and his content is live
YouTube lets it play they don't take his
content no they took no and and his uh
supporters as well so that that was that
that what that was after 2018. well
2018. remember 2018 was before 2020.
that's when social media big Tech went
crazy 2020. okay before that and it's a
very another similarity with the United
States after bolsonaro won doing this in
2018 with one million dollar in social
media they got together the system and
decided we cannot allow that to happen
again so we need to fight fake news and
all that and they started the censorship
that we have right now in Brazil we are
under censorship that's very important
to understand the uh the same thing
trusted news initiative uh all the the
fact checking International fact
checking even worse Polo even worse
because now we have legal decisions oh
that's that's a different yeah that's a
different level so we have the the
congressman Nicolas fejera he's a boson
Arista and uh he's very young and he he
was the 1.5 million votes he was the the
best uh candidate elected in in in this
election right now he's under censorship
in Brazil his uh social media I don't
want to get sidelined here but there's
the difference between the censorship in
the US and the censorship in Brazil okay
the the big Tech censorship in the
United States is private is protected by
the First Amendment it's something no
one knows how to fix yet but it's I own
Twitter I'm Elon Musk I want you out of
my company it's the same thing you don't
have to offer service to someone you
don't want to to to be your customer
okay it's one thing we we have to
discuss that but in Brazil you have that
but you also have
something that we didn't used to and
it's against the law in Brazil because
we have the courts
banishing people from social media and
not not even the cards sometimes only
Alexander de mores
own decision like one guy and says take
it off
is it true that it is a crime now to
doubt the outcome of the election it's
it's not a crime you can contest it's
legal to do that and the the
depends
party just did that officially yesterday
right it's a big news in Brazil right
now so they did it and it's legal the
problem is that uh Alexander de Morales
is treating everyone that contests or
complains about it as a criminal and the
mean the mainstream media is with him
it's at his side we got to give you some
context here to to understand because
that's a tough question okay so back on
the on the history the little story I
was telling uh so when bolsonaro got
elected and the system went nuts The
Establishment went nuts the first thing
one of the first thing that the Supreme
Court started doing was they created a
probe against fake news okay it was fake
news Pro and they did it in a very weird
way
because Brazil has the same accusatory
system which is the Bedrock of the
Western World due process of law so
what's the accusatory system you have uh
investigator an accuser an impartial
judge a defendant and victims everyone
is separated everyone that different
different agents playing different roles
so the Supreme Court they did something
that was never seen them never seen in
Brazil they opened the probe saying oh
there's a something on our internal
regimen our internal bylaws of the of
the of the Supreme Court saying that if
a crime happens inside Supreme Court
premises we can open an investigation we
can open a probe
so right now uh internet if someone says
something bad about us that's kind of
like it happened inside our court and
it's kind of an attack a crime and it's
people are criticizing us it's kind of
like an attack yeah attack to our
reputation they are a threat to
democracy because they are criticizing
us that's really what's going on I'm not
I'm not making this up I'm not making
this up it's hard to believe so they
were the victims of an attack
so they opened the investigator the
investigation and they brought a federal
police chief directly to report to them
so they were
they had control of the investigation as
well so they were the victims the
investigators they were also so the the
Department of Justice refused to take
part in in it because there's no crime
of fake news or whatever in Brazil so
they said no this is this whole thing is
is all illegal and you can't open an
investigation and we're not taking part
of it so they said okay we're gonna do
it without you so and it's like what the
constitution in Brazil says you can only
prosecute someone with the Department of
Justice it was the same as in the U.S a
judge can as much as generals Flynn
General Flynn's Justice judge uh tried
to prosecute them he couldn't because
the Department of Justice refused to
prosecute him so same thing in Brazil by
the law so and and again they did that
and they did a second one and then they
did it again they they came up with a
very similar one anti-democratic acts
about people demonstrating on the
streets and they were like this is
anti-democratic because you're asking
for a military intervention you're
you're protesting against institutions
so that's against democracy but there's
no under Brazilian Constitution you do
have one the right of free speech
two it's the the prior censorship is
forbidden you can't do it government can
uh impose prior censorship to no
individuals there's no crime of fake
news there's none on Brazilian they
tried to pass a legislation and they
failed if they make it yeah uh and and
but with all that they decided to do it
anyways so they started coming after and
without the due process they started to
arrest
journalists journalists congressmen
Congressman there was a congressman that
was arrested because of a crime of
opinion Community organizers they all
started to be arrested so and that that
started in the fake news probe and then
the anti-democratic probe all that that
happened and they they went after even
businessmen big businessmen I'm talking
for example the guy that owns the
biggest small uh chain and probably
Latin America and a huge investment here
by the way a huge investment here in the
U.S so I'm talking about a guy that owns
a like big retail stores like Sears in
Brazil uh they they started going after
supporters of personaro journalists
congressmen businessmen and and without
due process because they were not being
charged currently in the U.S there's a
guy living here in Florida a guy named
Alan DeSantis this guy is a journalist
he used to have the biggest Independent
News Channel in Brazil okay YouTube
channel
it was a business that was doing well
and this guy he's being investigated
under under Alessandro de Maurice probe
the fake news uh well then they changed
the fake news to digital militias uh
probe which they they switched the name
but it's the same thing
uh and militia in Brazil doesn't mean
the same thing as in the US it's it's
like a gang it's like an organized game
um
he just took his passport this way yes
they canceled his passport they issued
an arrest warrant against him he was in
the U.S so he stayed here he's under uh
political asylum in the United States
right now uh he uh he they froze in all
his accounts they closed his Media
Company
and and right now is in the United
States and that's The Best Is Yet To
Come Paulo is given a the whole View and
it's because you ask a tough question
yes is it illegal and I would say let me
know it's not illegal but it is but it
is in Practical terms let me give you
one example that one one huge uh
entrepreneur in Brazil uh the police
came to his office at six o'clock in the
morning seven o'clock in the morning his
crime was in a in a WhatsApp group
closed group they were talking about
Lula and the possibilities of Lula going
back to Power and the guy one of them
said oh I'd rather live in a
dictatorship than that and the guy like
sent a like
alike and that's it like if you liked it
he likes the message the message and the
police was at his place sick get out of
here and his and his private WhatsApp
group
wait wait wait a billionaire liked the
post I'd rather have a dictator not a
post what was the military government
yeah what's up
I'd rather have a military government
than having listen in office I was part
of the group I was part of I was in the
group and that's it no one's no one was
talking about a coupe there was no uh a
strategy of being built nothing it was
just complaining about Lula so let me be
clear because it's important and it's
important for the U.S to understand
Brazil right now is under a dictatorship
it's not it doesn't come from the
executive power it it comes from the
Judiciary there's no rule of law anymore
there's a rule of one person and this
guy that's what I what I said this guy
right looks like a bad guy from James
Bond movies he's doing all that and he's
kind of crazy I don't care there's no
one to stop me right now and and that's
the situation right now there are a lot
of people in the streets right now as we
speak and they are they are desperate
they are like please someone do
something and of course they look at the
the military power because that's what
what's left but this is nothing new
though this is it's been going on for a
while wouldn't you agree that this is
much worse much worse but what do you
think where do you see in absolutely
starting like at what point do you see
this power grab taking place internally
is that a presidential level is some of
the other bodies that taking power
taking control that's not something that
you can hide on the under the table
reflection points uh when Duma was in
pitched for example okay our
constitution listen I don't like our
Constitution that much it was written
one year before the Berlin Wall falls
down 1988 yeah so it's a very communist
Constitution but that's what we have and
the Constitution is very clear the 52
the 52nd article it's very clear when
you were in Pigeon you lose your
political powers for eight years so you
cannot be a candidate
the the Justice uh Lewandowski he just
torn it down and said no okay you can
you can go and she was a candidate to
the Senate she lost but she was able to
be a candidate and that what that was
the inflection point I think different
rules uh roots to it I mean when when
Montesquie came up with the three
branches of power system and and the
framers of the U.S Constitution they
came up with the they put it in place uh
and and they they always thought of
about the Judiciary for judicial branch
as a the weaker one right montesquis uh
used to say the their next to nothing
uh the and The Federalist Papers uh you
you see them saying well there's there's
no risk of uh Judiciary dictatorship
because they don't have the power of the
purse or the power of the sword so what
do they have they're they're bound to
the loss
and to the to the to the common law
and and and that's the way they thought
the system well that's that that's good
enough if you think that the judge needs
to stick by the loss
checks and balances so if it went when
so when you have a textualist or or or
generalist or or journalists it's not a
thing uh originalist like Scalia so
their bond to the intention of the
legislator
well if you have a progressive
view of the law the law is a living body
and the law with the purpose
teleological uh interpretation social
justice and all that social justice
you're not bound to that anymore so the
the N is what matters
okay so the means are irrelevant so if
you have to interpret the law and bend
it a little bit in order to achieve the
end that you desire
then things everything's permissible so
every judge is a dictator so my point on
the operation Car Wash and that brings
me to Sergio Moro is that I think Sergio
Morrow
uh mended the law
to achieve his purposes and operation
Car Wash was a big inflection point in
my opinion against the due process of
lime Brazil
and that's I I really believe that I I I
think bad guys went to jail which is
good but you don't have to only in in
the due process you don't have to only
be guilty you need to be prosecuted
under the due process of law and they
were not most of them were not and
Sergio Morrow and for political reasons
I believe and Deltona and other uh
prosecutors and they became politicians
and the the a good evidence for that
yeah is that Serge Amora became a
minister and now he's a senator Delta
delay all the prosecutor is now uh uh uh
Congressman a congressman Congressman
elect is this guy can you pull up uh
this picture so the audience can see it
is is this guy Alexander the more uh is
he a feared man I mean if you can zoom
in the picture a little bit yes he seems
like a very friendly guy
very friendly can I answer Patrick yeah
with a very straight answer I I'm not
going to Brazil anymore uh to visit none
of us I I have family there what happens
if you go to Brazil I'm afraid I'm
afraid I could be arrested for any crime
that they create would you say that this
guy is running the country yes oh yeah
absolutely yeah he's run the country of
course but he's not alone like you look
at him and you understand there are a
system a whole system corrupt pressure
behind him he wouldn't do that alone
come on he looks like a James Bond
villain yeah he is it looks like it's
it's probably the haircut it's the
haircut it's the way that he behaves
he's very weird he behaves I believe
he's a psychopath how did he technically
how did he get to power what did he do
before he was Tamer uh he was Tamer uh
Choice Minister of Justice Minister and
and he used to work for look at that
that's gonna be interesting he used to
work uh to Geraldo Alchemy who by the
way is the vice president elected with
Lula so look how impartial all that was
in Brazil Brazil our Justice you
wouldn't believe so one guy is the
former lawyer of the uh
Ms MST uh the the the how do I say that
we don't even have that in the United
States it's the government of people
that want to occupy uh lent like if you
see a farm farm and they go there and
they go and the Invaders they invade
land and they there's a legal movement
correct of that in Brazil Invaders okay
uh so one of these their lawyers is now
one of the Supreme Court Justices
a very weird uh pass I think we can say
that because we're in the U.S if if we
say that in Brazil right now we would be
in jail okay but he is his firm
um was lawyer of a company that was
accused of money laundry for Brazil's
largest drug cartel
uh that's that's a fact that's that's in
the news the conflict of interests are
here
for you to understand the another very
important name to this discussion that
we we haven't brought yet is uh Rodrigo
Pacheco oh yeah he's the president of
the Senate and under the checks and
balances system that Paulo was talking
about it comes to this to the Senate to
impeach one of those justices they are
the ones that could stop this
dictatorship right now and Rodrigo
Pacheco who owns a firm a law firm that
has a lot of interests in in the Supreme
Court System a lot of decisions that
they they need to do to make and then
it's going to impact a lot his firms he
doesn't do anything he says oh
everything is normal in Brazil now
institutions are working perfectly we
don't need to worry about so it's like
this guy is a Trader right now he's a
Trader he he's accomplished of this uh
Alexander de mores guy Rodrigo Paulo who
is who's your Lincoln who's your Reagan
who's your who's the the individual that
brought up the economy because you know
I pull up names and I'll I'll go and see
hey who is jetullio dornel dornellas
Vargas okay what did he do okay uh
joselino kubeck okay hey he took the
economy from 42nd economy to the eight
largest you know him uh uh that's who
that's uh that's uh that was under the
military rule that that's under the
military rule I read about your
grandfather right he was a former Chief
of Brazil Secret Service he was a
director of uh your secret service is
what uh he did and he brought democracy
back to Brazil and spent a lot of time
with Reagan I've seen him and Reagan
horseback riding together they spend
time together you know you go and you
look at tancredo Nevis this guy didn't
make it too long he gave his speech
after inauguration and then no no he
never inaugurated he died before he died
before inauguration and his vice
president Jose took over and then he
increased inflation to two thousand
percent is what he did froze prices to
try to control inflation causing
products to disappear from supermarkets
which led to a period of widespread
famine then comes Fernando Colo
Argentina is going through that I know I
wonder it was a very strange situation
there then you have Fernando color 1992
on the first day of government he froze
bank accounts of all Brazilians for 18
months yeah is that true for 18 months
with a maximum withdrawal of what would
be the equivalent of five thousand
dollars today he was impeached in a
second year in office for corruption
then you have itamar Franco he
stabilized the economy at a significant
cost bringing hope back to population
then you have Fernando cardoso 95-03
started Brazil transition to welfare
state raised federal taxes from 24 to 34
percent base interest rate of the
economy selik sclic reached 45 percent
per year then you have the Silva he does
what he does involved in the biggest
Corruption of all time then you have
Dilma then you have Michael then you
have uh it's amazing how brother
2019 2012. in addition to the high debt
and public deficit he inherited 14
million unemployed when he took over the
government uh even with the pandemic in
the war in Ukraine he ends up his term
with 8 million unemployed which is six
million more people working public debt
lower than ever when he entered
inflation Lord and the American and
economic growth higher than China uh we
are doing well
he he was very humble to admit that he
doesn't understand about economy so he
he named the guy he used to be my boss
for six years Paulo Gadis I think it's
the most important name in Brazil and at
least in terms of economics uh Paulo
gaddiso is a PhD from University of
Chicago he he studied with Milton
Friedman and all that and and he was
able to uh liberalize our economy during
this last four years even with the
pandemic and all that and he showed very
good results we did the biggest Pro
privatization in in 20 years with uh
electrobrise our Electric System company
it was the biggest in 20 years many many
reforms is not Reagan but but Paulo
Gattis was able to to to do a lot of
things Paulo like a Newt Gingrich or
Milton Friedman is that who Paolo is
yeah because Paulo and knude understood
a little bit of economy okay so the
criticism of bolsonaro gets more than 1
000 fires in the Amazon you know the
mishandling of covet that's the
criticism
is mishandling of uh of covid is pretty
much 99
what our governor did here in Florida
yeah that was that was his fault the
policy that he's tried to implement but
then the Supreme Court stepped in and
said it had no power and the power
belonged to the governors and and Mayors
which is the it is the system in the US
but it's not the legal system in Brazil
it's different we don't have a
federalist system who's your Reagan
who's your Lincoln who's your who we are
looking our society didn't produce uh
These Guys these are unique guys from
the American societies these are
exceptions in the world well I I would I
would say we have some very nice guys
the guys during the military government
I'm I have to say they did a very very
good job in certain senses such as well
such as bringing Brazil from the 47th uh
world's economy to to the who did that
who was the military president yeah
there was a the the
Bronco and uh
the surname of the economy the guy that
was with all those presents but during
the military power he he did very
important reforms the so just forgot his
name we we Brazil grew so much it grew a
China Pace during the military
government uh crime rates were very low
uh and and the problem is and that's the
problem the the freedom individual
Freedom uh was restricted and that's
when my grandfather stepped in and when
he took over he gave full amnesty to
political people that were being
politically prosecuted and he handled uh
and the the government to to the Civil
to the Civil Society back again oh
that's that's in a sense uh a sort of
um of a foundation of the country which
is very sad for me if you think about it
okay
yeah so if you think about it you
mentioned you mentioned
was a dictator uh kind of fascist in in
a certain sense he flirted with fascism
a very very leftist like he's a labor
party union guy union guy labor party
it's okay a new dictator so my grand
great grandfather was arrested and
prosecuted by him and spent years in in
jail because your great great great
grandfather got it so because he made a
revolution trying to uh seize power and
take him out of office not him cease
power but to take uh he was arrested and
all that so his his son
so someone that suffered under a
dictatorship became the present one day
which is interesting how history works
right and he was like no no my my father
suffered under dictatorship so I believe
in in the Western World liberal uh
liberally in the classic sense liberal
uh systems democracies so he said I'm
going to transition everything to a
liberal democracy and he did and that
was and that was a great thing but the
problem is and it's very set for me
personally to see that right now
he hadn't had to work so so hard to
transition from military government to
Civil Society in power and right now the
Civil Society is saying we failed we
want the military to step in again and
that's very sad for me personally yeah
because my family Legacy we opened the
politics before the economics and and
before and the Constitution came before
the the Berlin the Berlin Wall so and
you were talking about Amazon and all
those those are all narratives like uh
the globalism is very interested in
Brazil Amazon is very rich and all that
we have water we have Agriculture and
macron and all those people are saying
no Lula come here and uh to tell you the
truth I think like Lula is is selling at
the the Amazon and all that to those
guys to to to reach power bolsonaro was
the opposite he was like I don't care
what you're saying about Amazon it's
ours and uh it's a kind of sovereignty
with a nationalism like but we're gonna
protect what's what is ours and uh it is
the world right now is is looking at
this uh it's it's going on everywhere
like the globalism the the brucellas uh
bruxos but Brazil actually the Amazon
jungle Amazon forest uh lost
less during bolsonaro's term than on
under Lula's term and 84 is preserved 84
which is half of Brazil yeah territory
it's a Europe it's Europe
like everything is preserved yeah but if
you if you look at history though Latin
America goes through through that period
And I will say Latin America in general
because it was an overwhelming amount of
countries that for whatever reason found
themselves under the rule of the army
right so Armed Forces it was it was a
weird thing almost at the same time it
was absolutely happening in in is the
lowest period of crime for most of these
countries it's the lowest period of
corruption for most of this country and
then is the transition out of the army
into what is supposed to be a democratic
structure democratic government right
most countries right now going at the
same time through the face of the
Romanticism of Fidel Castro Cuba has
taken place uh uh from the Catholic
Church Thea Liberation theology is the
Gustavo Gutierrez takes on right and so
The Narrative of socialism it's already
happening there at that level so
countries are dividing themselves with a
group of people there are Central
Central Center right because they coming
out of that Army Foundation but
immediately right the philosophy and
everything that's being taught churches
and schools is Center left and
increasingly in some countries and start
going Center left when when Patrick was
asking a question who is you you know
who's your Ronald Reagan who is here in
that small window of time there's a
number of things happening including
it's not just the economy that's growing
the population basically quadrupled you
went from like 50 million to
215 million though so there's a lot to
control there listen if you're a
politician today if you're going to be
running for anything you have to know
what happened in history you have to
know what's taking place there and so
the The Narrative that it's got to be
put forward it's got to counter that
right so let me ask you a question what
do you think he did wrong
he's four years as a president he knows
that guy is there the other guy is there
he knows that this been around for so
many years you know too many battles
first okay like he he needed to be more
strategically uh a kind of person he
fought too many battles the media the
whole media was against him with fake
narratives he knew that going in he knew
that but he wasn't able to to write this
the smoothly like he misused social
media with the getting elected no I
think I think first of all during the
pandemics uh he could uh show a
different Behavior I I think so that was
one mistake not in terms of policies in
terms of policies it was just like Ron
DeSantis Fighting For Freedom against
this whole craziness uh uh around the
world but uh do you know Brother Brazil
reinstituted masks on airplanes
yesterday just just now why just now
Brazil reinstituted masks
mandatory yeah it's like what I read
this and I was just as surprised as you
it's like what for what I woke up with
these news there's they're different
rules and I'm gonna I'm gonna bring it
right there just two months after a
lifting uh a long-standing mask mandate
for airports and aircraft Brazil has
reinstated the policy but will not go as
far as a ban in Flight meal service
again Brazil's health authority on Visa
announced the changes this week and the
Mandate will go into effect on Friday
November 25th you gotta be kidding I
don't make things up I know I know
people that are watching me are like
this this guy is full of he's making
things up and not nothing that I'm
talking everything is made up
everything's true well you have your own
research problems with FDA Dr fauci but
in Brazil everything is worse so I think
he could like show a different behavior
for especially for the uh the people
that like the the Aesthetics point of
life like I need this guy cares about me
he's he's saying nice things and
bolsonaro is not like this as we
mentioned he's like a what you get is
what you pay for but uh people don't
like it some some people especially in
the he's not a stranger he's not a
strategist and and to to quote we
mentioned a guy here called Professor
olavu jicavalo he's uh he's he Rodrigo
mentioned him he's uh probably the most
important thinker in Brazil and what he
used to say he before he passed away he
recently passed away a few months ago he
used to say that bolsonaro's election
was a miracle to Brazilian society and
it was it was just a miracle uh and he
the the main idea is the same as the
Breitbart Doctrine the politics is
Downstream from culture and that's
that's the reason bolsonaro was a
miracle because the code neutral system
in Brazil is to
embedded by the left
so the the mistake that olavucho Cavallo
believed that bolsonaro did is that once
he took office he thought he'd he could
govern with all the structure uh of of
the establishment and still be able to
govern and and and he he needed to
change Central points in the society so
he would be able to govern I have a
personal it's it's an interesting point
of view but it's easier said than done
it is but I have a more practical point
of view I think and do you really
believe that he went in thinking like
that that he was going to be able to
change the attitudes a lot of structure
that has been I know for so many years
or just being naive as though he was of
course he was naive he was never in
office and I think he made a serious
mistake because politics in Brazil is
much easier than politics in the US in a
sense let me explain why if you're a
Republican president and you get elected
if you have the majority in the house or
the Senate you'll be able to approve
your and pass your bills that's that's
said no Democrat will vote for you most
of the times mentioning is an exception
most of the times no Democrat will vote
with a Republican and most of the times
Republicans removal will won't vote with
them Democrat in Brazil the system's 31
parties so and and the they're very
they're not ideological Congress members
are not ideological as they are in the
U.S so you can pretty much buy them I'm
not talking about bribe just to be clear
you you can buy their favors just with
political support you know it's crazy
you're saying this I'm at Harvard at an
executive program for three weeks and it
is the face of the class where
everybody's open dialogue they're
talking with each other there's 144 of
us from 60 plus countries and one of the
guys says you know I have a business we
had 25 percent of market share we were
doing great but a new business has come
up and it's taken six percent away from
me and it's really become a pain and
about for us it's annoying how how do
you guys handle this from from different
parts of the country
one of the guys he says uh well it's
very easy who's running for office and
he says what do you mean he says well in
Brazil what we do is you just look for
who's running for office that can help
pass some laws you give them some cash
and when they go in if they need a favor
they're going to pay their favor for you
create new regulations to her and the
way he said it he didn't have a smile on
his face he said it as if it's written
in business books that this is how you
put out a small business you know it was
very much of a matter of fact a way of
communicating but I want to go to this
well today with the conditions that's
going on Iran was playing England two
days ago they lost six to two Okay but
the main captain of the team they they
they didn't sing the national anthem it
was a very controversial thing to do
when you do something like that
you go up against the Iranian government
which who knows what's going to happen
when these guys go back because just a
couple weeks ago they're you know bowing
down to raisi and a lot of people were
not happy and then they go back if they
go and then they don't sing the Iranian
and Anthem because what they feel is
going on over there is unfortunate and
it's not fair on what they're doing to
the women all this stuff
anyways Brazil's the leading in Vegas
the odds are Brazil's number one
Argentina was number two until they lost
to Saudi Arabia and today is a national
holiday in Saudi Arabia I don't know if
people know this what happened because
they beat Argentina which I'm sure you
guys are very happy about right so how
much of this you think is going to play
a role in the world uh platform with the
Brazil playing and Neymar I think Neymar
said good things about bolsonaro if I'm
not mistaken it's an open open supporter
yeah he's an open supporter bubble
Center which is not common in American
Sports to be an open Support over Trump
you don't even talk about it since you
are same thing okay I mean we know Brady
had some relationship with Trump and
craft but Giselle is all about Lula
gisela's team lulas you know no gisela's
bolsonaro as well no she's uh Giselle
hasn't haven't said a word what I've
heard is she's more ruler than this
defend I'm gonna come out in her defense
because are you doing that because she's
singing is that what you're doing is
that why you're wrong oh no we have some
friends in common and uh you're an
opportunistic guy I'm impressed by you
I'm gonna I'm not gonna speak on her
behalf yeah but I'm gonna say I'm gonna
state that she is not pro Lula I've
heard no she's not I could well I'm just
telling you all right you can but he's
also saying he you know but it doesn't
know her okay it's important to
understand there's a lot of pressure
well she's got celebrities who don't
choose because everybody come out yeah
it's I think in gisela's case I think no
that's what happened well Gustavo Lima
came out Giselle did them doesn't want
to show any support to bolsonaro
because that would similarly disaster
so that's and that that's that's Gustavo
Lima country singer he doesn't care yeah
he doesn't care so so what what do you
think is going to happen with this whole
situation here well you think you think
Neymar is going to say anything you
think or they're just going to play the
game and go about business as usual and
no one's going to know what's really
going on yeah pretty much more or less
yeah listen it
soccer football
our football soccer in Brazil is very
popular and that's a religion that's a
religion and there's a like a a a
ongoing discussion about the uses of
soccer to politics correct so it's an
ongoing situation right now A lot of
people are on the streets they are
thinking that our future is going to be
decided in the next days or weeks we
could become the next Argentina the next
Venezuela or we could uh do something
and get rid of lulan and and all that so
they are not that interested many people
in Brazil are not that interested in the
World Cup right now because of that and
there's one guy very interesting if he
shows the picture he looks like a crazy
guy he used to be a presidential
candidate his name is Aeneas carnero and
aneneas
yes he used to say that when people in
Brazil uh
ignores soccer and vocals only on on
politics things are worried about the
breakouts but but maybe maybe what
what's going on right now is this but
one of the things that Patrick is saying
because Pat the captain of the team
comes out in a press conference
he this guy is putting his life at risk
what took that I mean and I'm not just
saying that this is a guy that if he
chooses to go back to Iran he more than
likely is facing death you know so
where's the temperature in Brazil right
now we're we're no we're we're not at
that level yeah yeah but but it's it's
it's amazing how things change fast and
I don't believe we would get to this
point we're not Iran it's a different
society different structure
but um but what he's saying is we have
we have credible fears to to go back to
Brazil and a lot of people are like that
they're I can't mention uh the person's
name but there's another person that's
here and the most as applying for Asylum
and the the amount of calls and I'm sure
you get it get them as well do you know
anyone do you know anyone personally
personally that has disappeared no no no
it doesn't it doesn't work like that
yeah no you what happened is for example
there's a guy a former president of a
party in Brazil ptb called Roberto
Jefferson okay Roberto Jefferson
he uh his last name is Jefferson
Jefferson in Brazil yes white guy white
guy yes uh and the thing is he was
arrested by Elizabeth okay
and in Brazil same to see the U.S like
Miranda laws right you get you get
arrested you have the right to an
attorney uh this is the first thing the
cop says to you right it's the same
thing in Brazil we have the same Miranda
Miranda rights right uh and but
alessandros decided on his uh arrest
warrant that he didn't have the right of
an attorney unless authorized by court
it's like what authorized by Court no no
not only a lawyer not only an attorney
but he didn't have the right to see his
family or a priest
so he didn't disappear and he's sick by
the way and he has cancer well he has
cancer and he's mentally ill for sure
but for for because even the the D the
doj said no this guy's mentally you
let's commit him but before the doj
actually asked for his for him being
committed
a restaurant to avoid having him
committed instead of going to jail but
and and that's a way of Disappearing but
there's another way of Disappearing
right now
you
remember the world change how do you
disappear right now just delete every
the person's social media so you have a
congresswoman for example Banks Banks
Banks events their accounts yeah freezer
accounts they did that with more than 40
40 groups related to the trucks and uh
so so if you we have a for example he
mentioned the the most voted Congressman
in Brazil and kid called Nicholas he's
20 something year old most vote 1.5
million votes for congress that's huge
uh we have another lady uh the most
voted woman congresswoman in the country
a lady named zambali and she had her all
her social media accounts
as well she was Deep platformed by not
by Twitter not by big Tech all I'm
mentioning is by court orders yeah and
she was here last week with you yeah to
complex
yeah we filed a lawsuit on the
inter-american commission of Human
Rights because
this it's not focused on the elections
and we can talk about elections which is
a separate chapter but we filed a
lawsuit about violation of free speech
violation of freedom of the press
violation of due process violation of uh
Congressional immunity uh and and and
all that's ongoing in Brazil and
violation of right to protest so it's
it's a human right all that is in the
Declaration in the international
Declaration of Human Rights of the
United Nations and all that is part of
the uh San Jose De Costa Rica packed
that Brazil is a signer so and that's
why we filed a lawsuit a formal lawsuit
that's ongoing on the inter-american
court of Human Rights I filed as a
journalist she filed as a congresswoman
but and that's that's the equivalent of
Disappearing let's say we both of us we
work for on the same station in Brazil
it's the second largest to view news
station in Brazil
uh most some of our shows are number one
in the country
um it's it's and it's it's a
one-year-old television it's growing 80
88 year old company one-year-old
television was radio it was a radio yeah
it was a radio before that and our TV
station
got censored by court order there were
certain words we couldn't use they're
not going to believe it that's true
we were not supposed to say on air that
Lula is an ex-con is an ex-con or or his
guilty we are not supposed to say that
by court order
he gets off in a technicality 25 at
five thousand yeah five thousand dollars
and they have the right to answer to
answer and to respond to it on the same
dictatorship it is addictive it's a
prior prior to what we say and the
temperature is high like if you search
on Google uh what happened just
yesterday or or two days ago in goya's
Guyana I mean if that's the case they
invaded they invaded the assembly the
assembly the State Assembly because they
were trying to pass uh increases tax
increases and the the people are angry
in Brazil right now if that's the case
they're doing that what campaign would
be an interesting campaign if the people
from Brazil are listening to this and
you believe Lula is an ex-con a
fantastic hashtag would be hashtag Lula
X Khan oh no and let that go Trend and
that's because at this point the guy
that's running Twitter is a guy named
Ilana I don't know if you've heard Elon
this guy about Twitter right we try to
reach out to him because Twitter who was
being yeah he did reply to my my post
but we we
I don't believe he's aware of the
importance importance of Twitter in
Brazil right now because Twitter is
still censoring people more than the
courts because the courts can it's only
can they do that though well because of
course you can hired more than half the
people mainstream media pressure no no
no no no no no employees in Brazil are
the same still the same they fire half
of it but the other half how many
employees Twitter Brazil how many
employees does uh I don't know but 80 of
them have a lot of purple hair so it's
like did you hear about what Elon found
yesterday in his uh office did you see
what he showed yesterday in his office
go to your last Twitter account and show
the little clip of 15 seconds and with
the audio on it uh pretty wild what Elon
found yesterday in his office at Twitter
headquarters which is like what the hell
go to Media go to Media okay so it's the
pops up okay actually go back there you
go right there yeah do the audio
do the audio so we can enter at the
merch thing and there's an entire
entire closet full of secret closet of
hashtag woke the t-shirts here we are uh
yeah at the launch
things and there's an entire
entire this is employees at Twitter
wearing a shirt say stay woke pause it
the only thing they didn't do there is
work yeah do I look surprised so in
Brazil Twitter is still censoring people
so my my girlfriend's mother was
censored from Twitter I'm talking about
a 62 normal old lady from Brazil
and she's she was censored by Twitter
and and again second time and Twitter is
still censoring more Brazilians than the
Supreme Court because the Supreme Court
can only censor as so many people they
can they can't do it for thousands of
people but Twitter with their
staff and their algorithms and all that
they can they can ban more people and
and so just an example the hashtag
Brazil was stolen
it was a big hashtag started trending
after an Argentinian guy denounced uh
the the the the the problems with
Brazilian like he found inconsistencies
with the results with the results after
he denounced that in a live streaming uh
YouTube took down his live stream and
before he ended uh the the Twitter
hashtag Brazil was telling me was
trending and Twitter took the hashtag
down and that's the big tax censoring
not not court orders big Tech so who's
not censoring is YouTube sensor in his
Facebook sense screen is is anybody not
censoring no everybody's let me give you
an example I put the report of the
Argentinian guy with the inconsistence
in my telegram Channel okay I have a
telegram Channel with a little over a
hundred thousand people I put the
original report and I said I want people
to look into that and see if that's true
or not because that's what a journalist
do you ask for other experts opinions so
I make it public I made it public
I got a court order of the Supreme
electoral court so pure electoral Court
taking down my shutting down my telegram
account for a week
just for sharing a report
and I was like what
do I have access to the charges against
me nope I never received any citation
any I was never served I don't have
access to the process and by the way if
you guys don't know I think Rodrigo both
of you guys have over 1.1 million
followers on Twitter five million and
I'm not certified yet yeah I have 1.1
one not certified we've got to pay you
eight bucks hurry up and pay for eight
bucks you get that but and then you guys
both available for Android and you guys
both have a million subscriber Channel
but I want to talk about this one story
what Tucker said uh uh just uh three
weeks ago which is which is kind of
weird and why would America be
interested in this uh it's a story of um
Tucker Carlson calls out CIA and YouTube
for interfering in Brazil's election
talk across and questioned the narrow
presidential election and revealed that
YouTube announced it will be censoring
any posts that raised doubts about the
vote total so not only Brazilians are
not allowed to question the election
results but neither are Americans
YouTube said they are expanding their
existing election Integrity policy to a
prohibit uh content uh advancing false
claims that widespread fraud errors or
glitches occurred in 2022 election
presidential election Carlson also
accused the CIA of interfering in the
Brazilian election for over a year and
pressuring President bolsonaro's office
to not question the election results
Biden the CIA director personally per
share pressured bolsonaro's office to
accept the results of the election long
before the election took office why is
America so interested in Brazilian
Brazil's election I have a different
view of what happened there tell us so
this is what happened I believe Roy or
Associated Press publish a story about
this okay saying that the CIA director
he was in Brazil and that he pressured
bolsonaro directly this is a Reuters
article I think he's a right guy either
either writers or Associated Press would
what's the difference there's the same
yep mainstream leftist okay uh press
agencies uh one of them published the
story The goal of the story was to put
pressure on bolsonaro on the
International Community so he would
accept the results
so when the story broke out I contacted
my sources in in the bolsonaro's
administration and all of them said what
this is this never happened we talked
but we never even mentioned elections
this never happened I don't know where
this reporter uh came up with the story
and and and that was
and and of course CIA denied it because
it would be very weird for the CIA
the diplomacy doesn't work like that and
if bolsonaro received
something like that he would probably
tell the CIA director to go I don't know
somewhere else
and and I found very weird so that's why
I checked in both sides at night but
then Bernie Sanders in the U.S Senate
mentioned it
he mentions that the story
so then when he mentions the story the
story became a fact because it's now on
the sentence
records Okay so
I believe that was not actually and the
the guy that talked to to Tucker was
very good reporter Matthew tiermann good
friend of mine
um he's a very good reporter and I think
he he was accurate the way he reported
on Tucker uh but I don't believe this
was actually the CIA putting pressure on
bolsonaro I believe that was the Press
making up that the CIA was putting
pressure and then
the Democrats using the article to put
more pressure and pass something on the
I believe they pass emotion right yes
and the Senate that being said we have a
left-wing government in U.S right now
Biden he was one of the first to
recognize the results and congratulate
Lula so what I think is going on is that
we need to go back to the beginning the
premise
bolsonaro in in the International
Community the mainstream politicians all
left-wing all globalists bosonaries like
Trump and both are fascists both are a
threat to democracy so they they came up
with this narrative and then they
believe in it and uh oh come on you need
to recognize the results are you gonna
accept it are you gonna accept or not
they are putting pressure because they
they know what's going on like and I
understand what you're saying though but
but like you know Patrick when he
introduce me was Tony that you know we
we actually do business with each other
you know he actually found a
a company of financial services and I
own a division within the company right
and so here's one of the things and I'm
going to approach this from a business
perspective right something goes wrong
right this idea of blaming everybody
else on the planet doesn't work here you
got to start by taking ownership right
so I want to go to a couple of points
and I want to know if you agree on some
of the things that because and let me
tell you where I'm coming from I believe
that there was truly a missed
opportunity on not only from Brazil but
also for United States with Trump right
so it's safe to say it can we all agree
that he mishandled the whole situation
with covet
for multiple reasons not just what his
hands on my initial position well he
lost political capital okay I think he
he but who didn't who did it in the
world yeah who did it in the world
if you look look in every country
look in every country in Europe
government's changed
in the U.S the president with the
economy doing fantastic although I
cannot say what I believe happened in
the U.S elections and I'm not a
conspiracy theorist the reason I cannot
say is because we're on YouTube so that
tells a lot of what we're saying who
didn't but I'm not just talking about
the social media opinion or his
perspective but here's something that
happened in Brazil premise before that
no he didn't lose did he lose that the
first question I come from the financial
service as well I need to think I'll
I'll need to take a responsibility
accountability taking ownership yeah
take ownership but the first question is
did he really lose I don't know I don't
know but again let's let's move that to
a side because let's this this
definitely I mean I think we can agree
that there's a lot of self-inflicted
wounds here right right that didn't help
him at all I agree so so I'm not just
talking about his social media position
things that he said to the media I'm
actually talking about the largest
welfare program program that was
actually set up in Brazil under his
presidency where they were actually
giving away what was it about 1100 per
month which the average by the way what
how much do they make dollars no it was
actually it was five times less than
that it was actually 600 hash yeah a
little a little over a hundred dollars a
month yeah
okay so but it was huge from Brazil yeah
yeah it was huge it was bad yeah so so
here so you agreed to do that right by
the way in many ways Trump ended up
making the same mistake right a lot of
money goes out because everybody Panic a
little bit right though the what is the
right thing to do I agree with you
nobody was clear about right but now you
set up a program you're going into an
election that program ended no he right
before the election no he reinstated the
program it's still going on it's ongoing
he said he promised that he he he would
keep it next year so it was not a huge
issue but at this moment is it going on
or is that it is ongoing it is going on
and it's what it's not it was not a big
issue in the campaign so public opinion
you know I mean and again outside of
because here here's a couple of things
there that that people out on the street
right remember coming out from the same
background in Honduras this is also
normal to hear somebody saying Hey
listen
Lula is is uh you know he took some
money he was probably corrupt but but
you know he cared for the people and he
did things for the people and by the way
during the time that he was a president
which is correct it's a correct
assessment regardless of the reasons
right
the economy was doing well the economy
was growing things were going well it's
doing yeah so so uh you know bolsonaro
is is is pro-business you know I mean
and Lula comes out saying I'm Pro people
right uh I'm pro life
um pro-choice by the way a lot of those
issues right that today are becoming an
issue in the United States you know the
the it's safe to say that Brazil is more
liberal in certain things right you know
when you see the carnival and you see uh
an abortion weapons we're much more
unfortunately uh
you know something percent of population
Resort against abortions the transgender
conversation was something yeah so so in
in Brazil
uh oh is there a Planned Parenthood in
Brazil no abortion in Brazil is illegal
it's illegal illegal illegal or illegal
it's a crime actually and both sides
agree on that no no no no the left are
trying to push but but it's a minority
yeah so it's a it's 20. did you say what
percentage 90 what well nine percent 90
according to bolsonaro's internal
campaign polls which I trust more than
the public polls
90 yes it's important to understand even
the left-wing candidates or during the
campaign
yeah they changed they changed the
narratives they say that they are
against abortion for example so even
Lula says he started saying he was for
abortion in an International Event yeah
because Mula is not always in is uh
sober okay so I don't know yes it's true
he's not always sober uh so and and I
don't know if he was or not but in an
event he said no you know what it's a
shame that in Brazil boo women they have
to die seeking for an abortion and all
that this is the same narrative those
Americans are used to so he said that he
was repeating the international left
narrative and and about the not always
being sober it's not a joke like if you
if you go Google Larry Rother the New
York Times uh reporter in Brazil during
the first year of Lula's uh term in 2000
country he was almost expelled from the
country because he was celebrating the
whole year he wrote about Lula's not
being sober alcohol
habits uh but but he the backlash when
he's he was sad that he was pro-abortion
uh was so big that he had he needed to
back battle and say oh no it's not what
I meant I'm actually against abortion
and he was challenged by that in the
last presidential debate are you
familiar with El Pais yeah sure okay so
I want to read this paper to you this
article they wrote several reasons yeah
I know that's what I'm saying you can
correct it seven reasons why by the way
who's El Pais and U.S if you could if
you can tell us who El Pais is well who
would they be in U.S would it be New
York Times okay so seven reasons why
Lula won Brazil's presidential election
number one the fear of authoritarianism
okay while many Brazilians haven't
forgotten Lula for the corruption that
played his uh two previous
administration there was a pervasive
fear across population for bolsonaro
former Army Captain was leading the
country towards dictatorship bolsonaro
who repeatedly hinted that he wouldn't
recognize an election defeat in 202
appointed members of Brazilian Armed
Forces to key government pose during his
administration that's number one number
two the pandemic bolsonaro's
mismanagement of the pandemic which led
to Deaths of uh seven hundred thousand
okay and it was slow to bring the
vaccines and buy them etc etc three the
power of alliances Lula as he did in his
previous two elector electoral victories
expanded his base welcoming parties from
the left center right into his Coalition
the fact that his running mate was a
Geraldo uh Alka alcamine a center Right
leader who was defeated by Lula during
2006 presidential election drew the
attention to many moderators who don't
typically support Lula's Workers Party
4. Nostalgia the Northeast region of
Brazil made up of nine poor and racially
diverse States gave Lola Landslide
victories voters had fond memories of
his tenure which dramatically reduced
poverty created social programs and
improved Healthcare and educational
access okay so that's that part five the
Jefferson effect which we talked about
earlier
both an Earth's close relationship with
Roberto Jefferson an ex-congressman who
recently shot and Drew a grenade at
police officers when they came to arrest
him left a bad taste in the The
Electoral uh uh uh his mouth the ability
to compromise after being sworn in next
year Lula will have to govern with a
Congress that is dominated by
conservative parties bolsonaro is a
liberal party will control 99 seats a
fifth of the Chamber of deputies many
Centrist Brazilians likely saw that
after the strong showing for the hard
right in the first round the country
would require a consultory president to
build a functioning legislative majority
and last but not least
the Evangelical community
a third of Brazilian Brazil's population
more than 65 million people identifies
as Evangelical Christians in the first
round nearly 70 percent of these
adherence votes voted for bolsonaro's
socially conservative program but Lula
held this own with this group spending
the last days of the runoff election
doing Outreach amongst evangelicals he
had denounced the lies being spread by
bolsonaro even wrote a letter to the
Christians in which he promised to never
restrict religious freedom this is a
very nice article about Lula how much of
this is right how much of this is wrong
are some some true fifty percent okay
like Roberto Jefferson grenade issue
hell we don't know we don't know the
effect but we do know that he said
something about the Jews and kids and
the children comments uh on Instagram
post oh Jefferson Jefferson no Jefferson
it's kind of a crazy guy right now but
the problem this was not that and he's
well he's sad it's funny because what he
said was completely true in essence uh
he mentioned so because and that's
important to understand during elections
the court in Brazil the superior
electoral Court gave themselves
temporary special powers let me put it
this way okay and that was contested on
the Supreme Court
because Alessandro de morage right now
we're still during election period until
the certification okay yes we're so
we're so so this this what happened is
that they gave themselves special powers
and I'll assumed them what I could take
down by himself out of his own will any
content in any person he wanted from
social media so that was contests on the
Supreme Court which Alessandra is also a
part of but anyways uh the and when one
of the justices a lady
Carmen Lucia he said well what's going
on it's kind of like sensor censorship
which is forbidden by our Constitution
and but I think this is just temporary
and after elections we need to look this
over so about the Jefferson heard that
and he compared her to a [ __ ]
okay that said I'm just gonna
I can't say that it's it's and then he
apologized to the horse yes and said I'm
sorry to all the [ __ ]
that I'm comparing you to Carmen Luther
and that's funny as hell but and look if
you did that in the U.S
it would it would be you'd be unpolite
probably but you wouldn't go to jail to
say that about I don't know Sotomayor
whatever and and so but on the couple of
daylight days later
uh that's why the federal police went to
his house to arrest him and actually
arrest him for a second time because he
was also uh being investigated and
undirected during the weekend uh it was
it was nuts it was nuts and then he
received the police with the With
Grenades and and shot the police because
uh I don't know but that if even even if
I don't believe that had an effect on
their life I believe it had I don't I
believe it had because how it it is
perceived by the the whole public so I
think that there is a lot of people in
Brazil that thinks Boston now is too
radical that that that that is a fact
and those kind of things they they don't
have maybe had anything was not a
statistically uh relevant because I I
used to get bolsonaro's internal polls
every day so and one that was a big
problem during the campaign and they
looked at it and they said wow we
thought that this was going to affect us
it didn't most people didn't even know
who Roberto Jefferson yeah the
Evangelical Community yes Lula tried to
convince them he was not a bad guy but I
don't think he succeeded 70 of them
still voted for both of them what is
true there and I think it's uh it it was
very important compared to what though
what was the first time 2018 what was
the the year the Evangelical yeah did
they go 90 no no no it was about that it
was about that
evangelicals are getting more
conservative in Brazil because
evangelicals in the in Brazil are
different from Americans evangelicals
they're uh here is very very politicized
the churches are very connected and
devoted to the Republican party is again
around 65 70 as well in Brazil it didn't
used to be like that actually most of
the Evangelical pastors supported Lula
uh and and so what were you said about
the Catholic Church though so and that's
a whole whole different subject so what
do you think could happen with that uh
you you you you spoke well of Theology
of uh Liberation theology
and that's one aspect the other is
Brazil saw the decline of the number of
Catholics and a lot of Catholics in
Brazil are so-called Capital Catholics
they say they're Catholics just like my
dad so supposedly a Catholic never took
me to I mean it never took me to a mass
so how come he's a Catholic uh you don't
do the sacraments you don't believe in
the pope so you're not a Catholic so
there's so-called Catholic it's just
because you're baptized or stuff like
that it's like juice yeah some juice but
listen in America the most important
thing there I think was the support from
very famous and respected liberal
economists like Amino Fraga who used to
be the former Central Bank president
who used to be a minister uh uh sent a
former Central Banker uh in in Lula's
Administration those guys are seen as
very moderate very uh pro-markered and
stuff like this and they gave their
support to Lula so they they helped
build this fantasy for me it's an
illusion correct that Lula is more
moderate right now more Center and that
helped but you know what they they are
uh uh complaining already yeah would you
say drawings through their support weeks
guys but will you say that today today
the Catholic church in Brazil is a left
socialist
part of it yeah most most of will they
be like like if you have to look at the
group right now and and go to a
percentage
who voted for Lula today oh no I know
the numbers who voted for Lula okay uh
so actually Lula won among Catholics I
think believe he had 60 off Catholic
votes according against to bolsonaro's
campaign's internal polls 60 uh were I
agree with that number but there are
Catholics like Nancy Pelosi like
Catholics pro-abortion and stuff like
this they don't no I get it it's a big
number you know I mean
in a good shape in Brazil so we have you
have two three things you have the
decline of the number of Catholics you
have the decline on the quality of
Catholics according to Catholic theology
which I'm very fond of and you also have
the Theology of the Liberation theology
which is very prominent in Latin America
so you have all three of that making
like like he said uh there's a part of
Catholics in Brazil that support
abortion it's a small percentage of
Catholics in Brazil but still and you
have a lot of a lot of them there are
not even they never went to church they
don't care so our our current our
current pope who do you think he would
have voted for
um
if I may let me go back to Armenia frog
and those names very very
important names internationally Amino
Fraga used to work with George Soros and
his very wealthy and all that so uh
those uh supports uh were very important
for Lula and they already as Paulo said
they are they are already withdrawing uh
days after why because what I think
happened is that those guys hated
bolsonaro and they wanted to grab power
so maybe made Alice or a mini frag I
thought they would be minister of uh
Finance economics and stuff like this
but we have already more than 300 names
in the transition team
okay 300 names already and those are bad
names like a lot of them are connected
to the uh last government of Lula the
corruption side of it a lot of names in
the economics are very radical too
radical too left-wing uh they are
considered Fernando adagi who lost the
the Sao Paulo government election they
are considering Fernando Dodge as the
most likely next minister
he this guy sucks at this he doesn't
understand anything about economics so
uh those uh important names that gave
their support to Lula they are already
uh they regret it already but why they
did it I know why they did it
you know what's the biggest political
split in the world right now it's not
left and right it's people that trust
and read mainstream media and people who
doesn't that's it it's it's not more
left and right if if someone is captured
by mainstream media
they're gone and but once they stop
believing in it it's like taking the red
pill and and that's the division in
Brazil these guys they all read or
Global they all read the New York Times
they all go to New York to the beautiful
people uh beautiful people's party so
you're either and and there there's a
lot of good people there's against
bolsonaro why because they believe in
the media so when you ask me what was
the reason yes we need to take ownership
but there's nothing you can do when your
country has 48 of the people believing
in mainstream media which is a leftist
propaganda machine there's nothing
bolsonaro could have done nothing he
could have done to better and he made a
lot of mistakes but it didn't matter
because let's take Donald Trump okay he
had the best press secretary best press
secretary I've ever seen in my life
Kaylee McNamee she's unbelievable I've
never seen someone anyone so well versed
on on her job
reporters used to ask her questions she
was like okay he was like open her
binder it's like how how is she doing
that and she would have the answers
compared to this lady that we have right
now which is a disgrace she can barely
talk and Biden has all the support of
the mainstream media so it doesn't
matter if you have Compton people around
you the media hates bolsonaro let me ask
the media hates Trump yeah let me ask
this question here so and we're getting
to the end of the podcast so what's
gonna happen next meaning you know oh
okay he hasn't conceded okay and he's
not made the phone call but at the same
time you think he's not gonna put it
yeah I don't think he's I don't think
he's he doesn't have to yeah but at the
same time you know what what can they do
to him you know how he got up he says
there's only three one of three things
that's gonna happen to me they're gonna
have to kill me they're gonna have to
arrest me or they're gonna have to we're
gonna you know he got up and gives that
message okay
so what what are they going to do to him
next is he going to be going away
anytime soon is he still going to stay
loud are they going to try to silence
him because you know when when even
after the election if they follow if you
if if this is the same Playbook being
played okay on the left and the right
and your son bolsonaro is Trump of
Brazil you know what comes next is they
gotta de-platform him from everywhere
which is Twitter which is Facebook which
is YouTube which is all of that right
is is that how they're going to silence
him and is he gonna stay in Brazil is he
gonna leave is he going to get her what
are they going to do to him knowing the
history of Brazil what do you think is
going to happen next to him so you
Rodrigo mentioned that yesterday
bolsonaro's party officially challenged
election I read that yeah correct okay
the claims are hard to deny
okay claims are very hard to deny
um the the the the whole system is is
plotted
okay and I I was part of the people that
say that said after the the first uh
round of the elections I said no no I
don't see any evidence of you know what
are the chances of things flipping when
Supreme Court owns 9 out of 11 in
Alexander that let me yes that's
important yeah so he he challenged not
spoiler alert Supreme Court's not going
to say anything but the law in Brazil
says the attorney general has has to
ask for new election okay
and the court might deny it again
or you're talking about a guy in the
Constitution 1988 communist Constitution
that says if you get impeached you can't
run again for eight years but then the
judge says hey let's rip it apart it's
okay not this time and she can run again
so if they have a reputation of doing
that and they own 9 out of 11.
I mean there's there's an expectation
Trump had six three Supreme Court and
nothing happened you know so that that
you know what which is the the biggest
difference from Brazil and United States
I think is the military yes he's correct
because the institutions are against
people that was going to be my question
they're gonna ignore uh so they're
exhausting all the institutional what is
their their position today and by the
way will you consider the situation
still a center institution independent
enough the the military the military
military they're legalists they follow
the law they they're a strict and they
want they kind of don't accept uh what
happened in Brazil and and Lula being
the commander-in-chief uh like they they
are we have some general uh Tweeting or
uh two two a week ago the The Joint
Chiefs issued as a joint statement which
is I've never seen it happening and it's
Strong saying that they're listening to
the streets and that they're
hoping that our institutions listen to
the streets and fix what's going on
and but they use a very weird language
on the text saying we have the role of
the Protectors of democracy and
institutions and throughout history we
exerted the role as moderators of
countries conflicts and and then they
put pressure on the Congress like you
need to do something because we are
watching what's going on so nobody knows
what's what's going to happen like the
people in on the streets right now they
believe they still believe Lula won't be
able to to be the next president they
still believe that there's a large chunk
of that I have a very I mean listen it's
it's well we're not optimistic as well
yeah I I have the only reason the only
reason I have a very hard time uh
Alexander this guy first of all is 54
years old that's not good news for you
he's not 78 he's 54. he was born in 68
that's a young man right there yeah he
ain't going away for a long time and he
seems like he works out and he's pretty
energized and he drinks coffee so this
guy's going to be fired up for a long
time this is not not good news you asked
some somebody
that's that's what's going on in jail
like he should be arrested we have a a a
a judge that just retired yeah he just
retired and he gave a very strong very
powerful speech to the guys to the
people on the streets the pills
Scorchers yeah he's retired yeah and his
he just retired but that's retired no no
I know but that's not he understand the
the law he's acknowledgmental yeah and
he was like very quietly saying that
Alessandra de mores needs to be arrested
who has the power to do that the
president could anyone could ask this
the next time the next time uh uh and by
the way I'm not trying to take hope away
or anything like that I'm just saying
nine out of 11 and the last time uh uh
when he won uh let's not forget Obama
called Lula one of the best politicians
in the world and he was on Time Magazine
2010 one of the top 100 most inflation
men in the world that's Lula we're
talking about he knows how to Market
himself he's only he knows how to sell
himself and he knows how to play the
game he's been around for a very very
long time playing this game he's a pro
amongst Pros to pin who against who he
knows how to talk to the Evangelical and
kind of persuade this I'll strategize
he's he is he is the credit goes to him
as a strategist I don't agree with his
policies I don't agree he has the world
community and then the other part with
China he's not as smart as you think you
just have he just has a lot of strategy
is not necessarily smart to me strategy
is wise to me smart is intellectual
educated degrees you you do not want to
go against a wise competitor let me tell
you you would much rather go against a
smart competitor than a wise do you
believe Joe Biden's wise do I believe
Joe Biden is what wise wives wives he
has one wife wise why no Wise Wise
wisdom
you mentioned wisdom uh uh no but I do
believe Obama is wise because to me Lula
is Obama and Obama's running America not
a lot of people think of Biden's running
America people people think who was just
a symbol no for the establishment but no
hear me out though when midterms were
taking place who went campaigning
Obama or Biden Obama Biden wasn't
campaigning anywhere because Biden Obama
is Lula and Obama didn't get up there
talking about how Biden's one of the
greatest presidents and leaders of all
time Biden Obama got up there and talked
about what he said democracy is at a
threat that was the line everybody used
the exact same University threat and the
same thing
so Lula is Obama Obama is Lula and
they're both wise I don't I don't agree
with that say well then
Obama Obama is very very wise and smart
yes he's a double he's got both right
little is not but can we approach it
from a different perspective because
because well it's not that small level
of Street Smart what were you telling me
Lula doesn't have Street Smart go to
jail for 580 days go hang out with
criminals he didn't hang out with
criminals he wasn't a VIP coming up from
the beginning at the beginning where he
wasn't what he was doing with the
community organization well that's
that's he went to jail for a month back
then I mean he I kind of agree with you
more on this issue because he's a
survival and during the military uh
Power in Brazil he he used to to do both
sides he he's a survivor
so yes he is wise he knows how to deal
with it but but the establishment is
stronger than him so if he thinks he's
gonna rule like Venezuela he's gonna be
uh I don't think that he's gonna be gone
I don't think that's I don't see Brazil
going at the levels of of Venezuela
because of the establishment I don't see
that happen again listen it's not my
country I'm just giving my uh you know
from the outside scene what's going on
in America and I see Brazil's following
Us's footsteps the American situation is
was more optimistic for something
happened with the elections because they
had six to three Supreme Courts so Trump
is sitting there saying I own Supreme
Court I'm going to fight it they're
going to back me up because I gave these
guys the job and it's going to be this
no they didn't want to do it and you're
talking about Brazil nine out of
Institutions institutions here is a way
stronger in Brazil the only hope they're
trying to follow all the institutions
yeah every single one in them yeah but
here's what doesn't change though don't
work but that's the only chance if they
don't work if they for some reason
there's an expectation of the military
intervening under Bolson hours I don't
believe that will happen I think that's
unlikely but that's
no there's no Civil War because there's
no to have a civil war you need to have
another side with guns the other side is
the the criminal the criminal it's the
criminal they're easily dealers and
they're easily controlled by the
military that's there's no risk of Civil
War if the military stepped in the steps
steps in uh what we'll have is the
pressure of International Community is
this video correct can you pull up that
you know what the risk of civil war is
that is accurate video yeah I believe
that's September 7th that's September
7th yes the Independence Day in Brazil
you know what is the Civil War risk in
my opinion is if there the terrorists
don't do anything oh yeah now we have a
risk yep guys listen you're you and they
they are not happy at all you're
underestimating that number one
role in in in in in the number one thing
that a politician is trying to
accomplish is to get on power to get
elected that's the number one thing
right so so so so it's very it's not so
much even a question of wisdom or
intelligence is that there is the
country by the way Latin America even
our country is already flowing in
certain direction that's an easy thing
to sell here's my problem though my
problem is that even as we are having
this conversation right now we're still
not making a good argument as to why
bolsonaro the fact of the matter is that
he lost some Catholics he loves blacks
and pardos right he's like
he is to blame of course he has to blame
part of it it does this there's a lot of
videos so even Evangelical saying listen
I know what my church is saying I know
that but it was too much of a of a
direct offense listen whether people are
blowing it out of proportion or they
know how to use the argument better what
I've been telling Pat for a long time is
here in the United States right now we
we have Democrats destroying the middle
class but they are making the argument
that they are the ones rescuing the
middle class you know why because
Republicans don't know how to make that
argument it's exactly what just happened
in Brazil you have a group of people
that maybe yes they had a better
platform they didn't know how to explain
it not only if they don't know how to
sell it you know you're still at this
very moment where just about every
mistake that was made here
is being made right now and so is that
an easy I agree partially with you but
the fact is one the difference one the
mainstream media the second is we don't
know if he actually won the election
that's my point we don't know our system
is completely flawed and there's the
mainstream and there's no way to verify
it though and there's no way no there's
no and my point being yes I'm usually a
Critic of bolsonaro for the same reasons
you are but I I can't I it wouldn't be
fair to to blame him completely because
of what no I'm not saying completely
yeah
that said we need to take some lessons
here
right I think the scientists for example
Ronda Sanchez is a name that learned
from uh Trump uh Trump in a lot of ways
but he learned also with the mistakes
like he's gonna be different in terms of
how he deals with the public I think in
Brazil if if Lula is the next president
of military uh forces don't do anything
and all that if that happens I think
we're gonna need a new uh wrong DeSantis
to learn from bolsonaro's mistakes
bolsonaro answering Patrick is going to
be still the huge the largest force in
the opposition you're going to jail
you're just going to jail you mentioned
you mentioned Peterson you know Peter
Buffalo is going to jail he's not going
to run again The Establishment in Brazil
there's no if he doesn't get out of the
country not only bolsonaro is going to
jail all his supporters are going to
jail
that's a very Doom scenario including us
and I'm going to be here oh but they're
going to try to arrest us Alan is here
as well of course they will they're
gonna come after every single one of us
yeah but see that's one of the reasons
why the military intervening is a
possibility because they know that they
know that they know they know they saw
what happened in Bolivia they know they
are the president of Bolivia yeah
they're not
yeah but I'm going back but without you
know you you mentioned Peterson before
what Peterson actually stated about
Trump was that his brand was winning his
brand was true manly his brand was I'm
abrasive I'm a manly I'm a man's man
right so that's bolsonaro so for Trump
to come out and say somebody stole the
election for me that goes against his
own brand you know what I mean and so at
this point though he he's just gonna
have to walk away if he doesn't do that
sad what he will learn his own brand
even more at this point it's got to be
the Army literally intervening
has a strong leadership off the right in
Brazil and he has been saying that you
know that there is a writer
I don't know that there is a right it's
not Trump's brand yeah but I don't know
that there is a Ryan in Brazil I think
you're very optimistic when you're
saying guys we grew up in that
environment I agree when I was 14 years
old I was I was exchange numbers
maybe they don't know they are right
wing or stuff like this but they they
share the same values and I think this
is larger than bolsonar to understand
bolsonaro and Trump I think one of the
best books I I I read was Victor Dave's
handsome from California called the case
for Trump and the case for Trump brings
the idea of the tragical hero
he's the kind of hero that is there only
because he is not in the bad side only
because of a kind of accident something
like this he's not a perfect hero he's
not a perfect guy he's the right guy
then the guy that you you need on that
time but then you get rid of him because
he's too loud or too messy and I think
what's going on in United States right
now is this they are looking for a wrong
distance as someone that brings the the
Trump uh stamina against the system but
in a more Wise Way in Brazil we're gonna
need that we have some names now we have
like the Minaj
I think there's another election result
I think there's another pessimistic they
stole the election it looks like they
have been stealing the election for many
years
doesn't matter it's the same thing I
think you just found another similarity
right the what got him elected is
basically what got him right God listen
I'm not going to argue with you against
fraud uh elections being listen like I
said um
Honduras right so it would be naive
right knowing what we know about how
these political games are played in our
countries by the way uh even even here
at this point right I think it's
extremely naive for people now to
believe this
Republicans are ever going to win
everything again do you think regardless
though everybody win Pennsylvania again
never so it doesn't matter the new
leaderships that came that come up yeah
but at some point you can break yeah but
some point you can break the system
that's what got Trump elected at some
point that's what got bush elected
that's what but you can yeah well well
but but look you see right now is he
gonna make it worse or actually that's
it that's what I'm telling you those
same things get they got him elected or
essentially the things that are getting
him not only fire in danger potentially
having the need to be in America
go for it it's kind of heavy metal yeah
against Jess like uh we we we can't
stand heavy metal for too long like
bolsonaro and Trump are two heavy metal
we kind of needed him them to fight the
the system or or to expose the system
but then we need to move on and and it's
important to adapt interesting
I enjoy the dialogue it looks like the
audience this is what we like to be a
little bit of a discourse debate banter
and you get to make a decision what you
think is going on uh my concern here is
purely stemmed from if China can have a
lot of influence over Brazil that's a
little too close to where we live and I
think there's one country everybody has
to keep their eyes on and that's China
because they got a big Vision on what
they want to do and they look at
everybody as beneath them they see
themselves as Superior to everybody and
this isn't about Brazil election this
isn't about us this is about you having
the freedom to build the life that you
want to build and some countries don't
want you to have that freedom to do uh
and build the life that you want to
build hence that be in China having said
that uh fellas a gentlemen thanks for
coming out Marvin awesome stuff really
enjoyed it with everyone uh we're gonna
put the link below to both of your you
you want to drive to the YouTube channel
or Twitter what would you like the
audience to Twitter
put the link for both of them uh on
Twitter on how to get a hold of them and
uh you know you guys are very active
there as well but with that being said
uh to everybody we're not going to do
another podcast this weekend which means
Happy Thanksgiving to enjoy the time
with your family we'll do the
announcement take care everybody bye-bye